Happiness -- many will advise you how to
obtain it but maybe you're not trying to
be happy. Your actions
aim for the opposite. You want to be the
saddest saddo sailing on the sea of
sadness -- much easier to achieve and this
video has 7 tactics to get you started
toward the dark currents, at least one of
which you are already doing. So let's
begin. First, stay still. Remain indoors as
much as possible, preferably in the same
room. Be the human equivalent of a pile
of laundry -- inert, unmoving. Don't let a
beautiful day tempt you for a walk. Avoid
anything even vaguely exercisial.
This keeps reward chemicals out of your
brain which could diverge you and
stillness guides you towards medical
problems which will keep this wheel
turning. Stillness is the most effective
thing you can do, so be the laundry pile.
Make your bedroom your allroom. Live and
work and play and sleep in the smallest
radius you can. Which brings us to screw
with your sleep. The wrath of insomnia
will be your co-pilot on the sea of
sadness. Her mere presence is unpleasant,
but she also helps confuse the
productive part of your brain which
might look to navigate you toward the
islands of happiness on the horizon. More on that later. A regular sleep cycle is a
fragile thing and takes at least three
days to establish. Be sure then to vary
your bedtime by several hours twice a
week, at least. Even better:
vary your wake time. Sleep in late,
preferably very late, some but not all
days. And tell yourself you are making up for sleep to feel like you're doing
something healthy even though you feel
terrible when you wake up early and when
you wake up late. Irregular sleep is
another of the sea's accelerating
currents. The more you vary your sleep,
the harder regular sleep becomes, which
makes your sleep more variable. To never
sleep or wake at the same time naturally
is the goal. And to help in this, maximize
your screen time. Staying on-screen
complements the previous sailing tactics.
Boredom could drive you to motion, so let
the screen entertain you. Tiredness can
push you to sleep, so let the screen keep
you awake, sort of, as long as possible.
Always fall asleep with a screen in your
hand and put your eyes back on it as
soon as you wake.
Every moment away from a screen is a
moment you might notice the horizon. Keep
your head down and let the currents pull
you. Here you have allies unknown. Behind
the screen are teams of the smartest
people and brightest bots competing to
hold your attention on them as long as
possible. Let them reach you to pull you
back if you turn away. Plus, screens
help with number four: use your screen to
stoke your negative emotions, to feed
your anger or anxiety about things over
which you have no control or influence.
Be well informed while doing nothing. The
things you care about could be
navigational guides out of the sea,
reasons to leave your allroom and take
meaningful action with the humans around
you. But you can instead use the things
you care about as further sources of
misery. Focus on the bad to fuel your
resentment or despair. If you must
contribute, do so only in meaningless
token ways and be disappointed in the
lack of change. We're coming towards the
end and if you're doing it right, misery
is descending. But some part of your
brain is rebelling, trying to turn the
ship by setting a goal. If you're not
careful, that part of your brain just
might save you, but luckily we can do
more than just hobble it. We can fool it
to navigate deeper into the sea. To reach
goals, they must be specific, measurable,
actionable, for which you are responsible,
and time bounded. I will turn the wheel
one degree right now. Instead, set the
productive part of your brain on vapid
goals: vague, amorphous, pie-in-the-sky,
irrelevant, delayed. Make the target
unclear and the path unclear. If
motivation strikes, aim ridiculously high
to guarantee failure. I will clean the
whole house today is much better than I
will do the laundry in this pile.
Cleaning a whole house is impossible.
There's always more to do, so you will
always fail. Focus on goals that are
after what you wish to achieve. Learn how
to market an app before you learn to
code. This will distract the productive
part of your brain quite nicely. And be
sure to wait for motivation rather than
setting a time. You'll do something when
you feel like it, which will be never or
never enough to matter. With vapid goals,
you will turn the productive part of
your brain from a dangerous source of
self-improvement that rewards
every small step into a consistent nag
that berates you for your failure to
have already accomplished your goal
every step of the way.
Now the vapid goals you've set should
distract the productive part of your
brain, but if it still fights against you,
direct it towards the mirage on the sea
of sadness: the islands of happiness
themselves. Pursue happiness directly. The
human mind is such that by setting sail
towards happiness, you will achieve the
opposite. Imagine happiness as a place
where happy people are happy all the
time.
This turns happiness into an unreachable
feeling of constant bliss that no one
has. True happiness is like a bird that
might land on your ship, but never if you
constantly stand guard to catch it.
Instead, improve your ship and sail into
warmer waters -- the bird will land when
you aren't looking. Uh -- so be sure never to
do that. Aim toward the mirage of
happiness rather than improving the ship
upon which you sail. Last, but most
important, follow your instincts.
Navigation deeper into the sea of
sadness is quite easy, for there is a
dark magnetic field that points the
compass of your impulses in the right
direction once you get started. You will
want to stay indoors, you will want to
not exercise, you will want to sleep in,
you will want to do what you know will
make you sadder after you've done it.
Your compass points the way, both in and
out, so follow the true north of your
impulses and stay away from that other
pole of the long-term. It's all so simple.
Just get started with these tactics and
let the sea carry you along.
This video was produced as an adaptation
of How to Be Miserable by Dr. Randy J.
Patterson, which is a great example of
how thinking about the opposite of your
goal can help you achieve what you
really want. And if you want to listen to
it for free
you can do so on Audible.com with their
free 30-day trial. Audible is the best
place to get your audiobooks. It's where
I get my audiobooks and you should too.
Audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audiobooks, original audio
shows, news, comedy, and more. If you want
to listen to it, Audible has it. Go to
audible.com/grey to get your free
audio book with a 30-day trial. There you
can get How to Be Miserable or any other
book that you want. We briefly covered
seven of the strategies from the book,
but there are 33 more and I highly
recommend that everyone read it to find
the ones that most resonate with you.
Audible is simply the best. You can
listen to your book anywhere, they will
always sync your place, and they have
a great listen guarantee. If you don't
like a book that you bought, you can just
swap it, no questions asked. Once again,
that's audible.com/grey for a free
30-day trial.